>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Sarah DeBacher: Hi,
everyone, my name is Sarah,
and I am the lead of the
Division of Education
at the Louisiana
Endowment for Humanities.
We are a state counsel
of the National Endowment
for the Humanities, and
I'm here to talk with you
about PRIME TIME Family Reading.
And our suite of programs
that support literacy
that begins in the lap of homes.
Because I'm in the room of
people who I know love books
and reading, I thought I
would begin with a story.
It is the story of reading with
my son who is six years old.
And somehow the real
Brothers Grimm version wound
up on our bookshelf.
It is not at all like
the Disney version,
and when we finished reading
this book, my son turned to me
and said, "Mom, why
does the queen care
so much about being pretty?"
He's six. We had a
discussion about feminism.
This is the kind of thing
that happens regularly
when the approach to learning
literacy is not the teacher
delivering content, who,
what, when, where, why,
those route approaches.
But, when the approach
is humanistic discussion,
humanistic conversation.
And we believe at PRIME Time
that it can happen
in all families.
The strategies that enhance
learning are here featured
in the PRIME TIME methodology,
we call them the
PRIME TIME Pillars,
they're essentially
learner centered, right?
They're about privileging the
people who are in the room
and the knowledge
that they possess.
They're about learning
through joy.
They're about talking about
books in ways that inspire,
love, and that connect the book
to the experience of the reader
who is reading and
talking about those books.
We believe that it's
important that programs
like PRIME TIME exist in part
because, of what's happening
in the schools that serve
families that are least likely
to have access to humanities
and humanistic pedagogies.
In other words, humanistic
pedagogies are most --
most often found in
elite settings, right?
Institutions of higher
learning, Parochial schools,
they're not found
commonly in public schools.
My son attends a public school,
and I work with teachers there,
I work with them to
help find more ways
of introducing conversation
into the classroom,
so that what Kelly
Gallagher refers to as
"Readocide" is not
happening in our classrooms.
This is the context of
the state of Louisiana,
which is where PRIME
TIME was built.
In 1991, in fact, librarians
around the state came together
to discuss the problem of
intergenerational illiteracy.
And how it was that we could
find a way to address that issue
when public schools were
not doing the best job
of addressing it there.
We now have a suite of
programs, at the heart
of it is PRIME TIME
Family Reading.
It occurs over 90 minutes, one
night a week for six weeks.
Families gather together to
eat a meal together, to read,
and discuss a book though
open-ended Socratic discussion.
And they all take a copy of
that humanities-based children
literature home in order to
build their home library.
PRIME TIME Preschool builds
on the family reading model,
but integrates families with
children who are three to five,
through center based
play that links
with the humanities
themes in the book.
And we also are now offering
teacher professional development
to support teachers, again,
in leading discussions
in the classroom.
We've been at it for a long
time, 26 years to be exact.
I know you can't
read this slide,
I'm not going to read it to you.
Please talk to me later
if you're interested
in our history.
I'd love for you to
be part of our future.
We remain relentlessly focused
on under-served audiences.
Gain, bringing elite
strategies to learning.
I don't know, the
shouldn't be elite.
Bringing just the
strategies that work
to learning to everyone.
Because, again, we believe
that everyone deserves
that kind of education.
Oh -- yes, I'm like, and
there's numbers here.
I realize that I -- I've been
seeing all these numbers,
and I'm like, I must
get the numbers in!
We -- over those 26 years,
we have, through the support
of our partners, such as
the National Endowment
for the Humanities,
worked in 40 states,
and with over 100,000
family members.
And we're just getting started!
Thirty seconds, whoo!
Oh, these are our families.
And I really just want to thank
all of you for inspiring --
like today, I think a lot
of this has been affirming,
you know, to hear of
the beat practices,
the work that you're all doing.
To be reminded that when we
come together through inquiry
and discussion, we come together
and talk, and enjoy literature,
and value and privilege the
people who are in the room,
and the -- everything
that they bring.
We don't make deficit
assumptions about them,
but we believe that they
have just as much to bring
to the conversation as
we literacy experts do.
That's how literacy
begins in the lap
of American families
through PRIME TIME.
Thank you so much
Library of Congress.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.